Hey, Ben.
Hi.
Hey guys.
How's it going?
Oh, it's fantastic, Conan.
(laughing)
How you guys doing?
We're okay.
It sounds like you're kind
of a little bit crying.
Are you okay, Ben?
Yeah.
I brought my boys with me here.
I'm doing great, I just
can't believe this is real.
This is real, this is really happening.
This is really happening.
Just so to clarify for
people who are listening
to the podcast, there's no visual here.
When he said, "I got my boys here"
he did not take out his testicles.
He held up two small dogs.
Oh God, come on.
These are my Chill Chums.
Oh, yes, your Chill Chums.
What are your dogs?
Those are two cute, little, scruffy dogs.
What are their names?
Yeah, so this is Teddy, the blonde one.
Yep.
AKA Teddy Bear.
Aw.
But I was thinking of
renaming him actually Kedakai.
Oh, Kedakai, very nice.
Yes.
You're in the know.
"Kedakai, as God made her."
As dog made him.
As dog, yes, there you go, there you go.